[Music]
duet AI is a tool for your development
workflow that can seriously speed up the
time it takes to get certain tasks done
what kind of tasks well rather than tell
you I'll show you I've been traveling
recently and like to know what the
weather is like where I'm going so let's
see how I can use the weather ai.com
current weather API and look up the
weather for any City on my
itinerary I know the basics of python
with flask but I don't use it day-to-day
so this should be an interesting test of
the code generation and completion I'll
start in
app.py and see what boilerplate duet AI
can create for me let's have a comment
that reads create a web page that allows
you to look up the weather
forecast for a location used using the
weather
ai.com current WEA
API and we'll just hit controll
enter all right now it's got some code
for me to see if I like it looks good so
let's accept that with
tab looking over the code I can see that
I need to replace the string that reads
your API key with my actual API key we
also need to create a couple of
templates for the HTML
page let's ask for a little help in
chat I need an HTML template that will
work with
render
template and has a form to get a city
name for the weather
API and and we'll create a file named
index.html and click this button to
directly copy the output to it now this
tool isn't much without the weather
results so let's ask dedi to help us
again for the results page I'd like to
get the current temperature and because
I'm visual I'd love to see the condition
including the
icon I need an HTML template temp that
will work with render template
method and will show the current
temperature and
condition including showing the icon as
an
image from the results we got from the
weather ai.com current
[Music]
API let's go back to the file explorer
create a new file
called weather.
HTML go back into duet Ai and copy into
the current file I've already updated
the app.yaml page and weather page after
checking it against the API so let's run
it and see what we
[Music]
get
here's our simple prompt I love Paris so
let's see what the weather is like
there ah I see it says the current
temperature is 39.2 De and the current
condition is
clear all right so I've integrated with
a public API to create a simple web page
in less than 10 minutes what will you do
with duet AI get started at .
[Music]
google.com/